so Donna city there's a understandably
you're building blocks for everything so
now we're gonna move into factorization
okay I hope this feels a bit like if you
just if I if I cover this web of complex
right this kind of looks a bit like he's
seven when you write maybe a nine now
that you know what this mathematical
universe is really made of it's like you
have to rewrite all the rules so my
graduation there Q plus eight now as two
units do this
you can do something with this complex
numbers completely aside how would you
factorize this thing okay good now at
what point now you guys are part of that
wonderful generation that has a
reference sheet I didn't have a
reference sheet so I don't memorize this
kind of thing
I will point out that the reference
sheet honestly the treated side of this
is not that you guys you guys should all
be able to have what I had which is all
of these kinds of results up here
because references there to help you
okay but as you can imagine it and as
you may have already discovered any
assessments we've had with a reference
tree the referee sheet comes with a time
penalty right you use it you're looking
for something not just saying I know
this and then you put down page okay the
extension one stuff that's but you guys
should all be able to do this like
without thinking okay it also helps you
not to have don't mean to something to
check it when I had to remember it I had
a new money for this you guys not
gnomonic write my name on it for this
was so because of course the hard plot
as we just noticed is the science
everyone else gets like the squares and
choosen that kind of thing so the signs
go like this this is a Miss applause
writes as sum of cubes so the signs that
you get this three of them they always
go like this same opposite always
positive notice that now if I if I
didn't think you'd minus a if I did the
difference of cubes this would be the
same - the opposite plus and this guy's
always a plus okay anyhow if that's to
you now as a two years dude or even an
extension wants to do that you would go
home at this point
okay it's done it is factorize there's
nothing more to do this question one
mark alright what you've done you might
like to put this read this over on the
side here what you do is you have fat
as this over there's a couple different
ways and ways to say this you could say
it's factorize over the set of real
numbers or you could say it's factorized
over the real number field okay it's
just a fancy flowery language name for
the set of real numbers but we can go
further now okay we know that this guy
over here we can deal with this no
matter how messy it is we can deal with
it because complex numbers allow us to
factorize anything okay now you can do
one of two things here have a look at
this yeah I can't think of a nice pair
of numbers that's gonna add two negative
two and multiply to 4 right so when you
get presented with a quadratic that you
can't factorize neatly what are the two
options you've got you can either go to
the formula right and then you get two
roots out and then you use the roots to
factorize or alternatively you can
complete this way okay now honest
question which ones you're gonna do
complete the square who would go for the
quadratic oil just out of curiosity okay
yeah cool now I'm just gonna tell you
right now when I was a year 11 I would
have probably gone to the quadratic
formula that was just what I was more
comfortable with completing the square
always we to be a little bit and always
had problems with it okay however I'm
gonna suggest it like now as a teacher
I've kind of gone the other way and I'll
tell you why number one you can't get
away from completing the square but you
can't avoid it as two unit students even
if you want to work out where on earth
the center you want to work out where
the center of that thing is right you're
gonna have to complete the square you
can have to do it twice okay so you
can't avoid this skill it's been like
graphing I know some people don't like
graphing cuz like oh it takes me forever
you can't get away from graphene you
might as well master it okay
kind of same deal here so let's all
together complete the square on this guy
right
you've got your Z plus 3 at the front
there happily see me now here's my Z
terms what do I do to complete this way
is that right it is right because the
way you complete the square is you have
this coefficient then you square it okay
so plus one is fine that leaves a plus
three over here yes like because that's
the four that we had before so that's
equal to zero okay now the reason we
added this one we took out the one
rather is so that now I can say this
part here can be rewritten as what was
there the minus one will sweat okay now
before I write the next bit right the
whole point of doing this is so I can
factorize a little more right but
something squared plus something squared
is no use to me or something plus
something but if I can have a difference
I can factorize that right I have a
difference of squares so I'm going to
rewrite this guy over here I'm going to
rewrite it as not plus but minus and of
course if I take a negative out well I
better put a negative in see what what I
did there right so complex numbers allow
us to muck with this a little more
because now I can factorize it further
yes okay let's have a go of it as n plus
two is still hanging out the front there
patiently waiting for us to get on with
the rest of it okay what's going to
happen he actually shouldn't run a
square bracket what's going to happen
here I can do difference of squares
what's a nice one
what's a be careful it's root three I do
you agree with that like if I square
root 3 I that will give me this okay so
I'm going to do this is a square minus B
Square in fact you may not even much
bread better this is a squared minus B
squared so what I need on the next line
is a minus B a plus B and you just
identify for me what a and B are so it
looks like this I think there's a there
is a minus B are you happy with that so
they did take careful there's the a
minus B now I need be a plus page that's
going to look like
a is still the same but this is plus
okay
are you feeling like an extension to Stu
yeah okay so this is this is hard to
wrap your head around and make sure you
accurately do your numbers okay but
that's it okay in fact is we're back
done now this is not factorize over the
real field we had to appeal to a new
kind of number to get to this point okay
so therefore it's they're saying that
rises over the real field you have
surprise surprise
after eyes this over the complex for you
now not only have you done that but I
want you to notice there's a qualitative
difference not just the fact that we've
used different numbers but there's a
qualitative difference between this line
and this line the last layer is better
for a very important reason this is what
we call in fact this is worth writing
onto another color we forgot it
this final white here is called the
linear factorization of the polynomial I
started with the meaning this
factorization now I'm a bit obsessive
names anyone who's been in my class
before knows that why is it called the
linear factorization as opposed to the a
factorization factorization yeah
suggestion
I can graph this right and grammar this
importantly when i graph it have a look
at these factors right like the
factorization is can you break something
up into its pieces okay all of the
factors are look at the powers of the
faculty students there's as n to the
power of one then there's another Z to
the power of one and then you get none
they're all straight lines okay as
opposed to go look at that real
factorization I've had before you've got
one of them one of them is a straight
line but the other one is a parabola
right so that's not a linear
factorization okay now linear
factorizations are awesome because they
tell you solutions right that's the
whole point of when I give you something
like XK plus 5 X plus 6
right the whole reason we obsess over
can you factorize that and be really
quick and accurate at it is so you can
give you the solutions very quickly ok
so now even though it wasn't the point
of the question I just wanted to
factorize you can all tell me what the
solutions to this are right
can you tell me Z equals this is one
easy solution of course 1 right which is
okay by the way negative 2 minus is an
operation negative is an adjective
negative 2 that's fine
what are the other two solutions look
carefully at this so for this one I need
1 plus root 3 I to balance this out so
that that becomes 0 1 plus root 3 I have
a look at this one what - huh
what are they school again complex
conjugates
there's never consent we'll come back to
that you now hold on a second
hold the front door what did we start
with at the beginning of this question
is it cute plus a equals zero now I can
rewrite this right I can just rewrite
this as Z cubed equals minus a now if I
gave that to you as a to Yunus student
or as an extension wants to do or even
is like a year eight student you said I
know the answer to that is the answer is
negative two and that's the only answer
right but now that you know there's more
to the universe than just the real
numbers you've thought of before now you
know there aren't just there isn't just
one answer there are three which is
exactly what you should expect because
you're taking the cube root right like
your square roots square roots this is
actually the next idea to kind of segue
into it right if I said to you Xen
squared equals 16 you know there are two
answers everyone knows there are two
answers even like little kids there are
two answers right and if I said to you
said to the fours at five you should
expect there's lots and lots of answers
this has three answers in fact Z to the
N equals anything always has n answers
right whether it's 2 or 3 or 50 it's
just that sometimes you can't see all of
them right at least what if you're on
the real field does that make sense
all right so let's just rewind because I
want to dig into these square roots I do
a little bit more what did we do here to
factorize okay first you factorize all
the stuff you normally can in fact
sometimes you can get past the key you
just factorizes over the rational field
a real field rather you can be asked to
factorize over any field you lie but
then realize you can go a bit further
okay if you wanted to you can obviously
use the Coretech for me if you feel more
comfortable with that but I advise if
you don't like completing the square
rather than running away from that
confront it because you can't avoid it
okay